I saw in the in the in in my hotel I get
it if you love your dog and you want to
bring dogs and you want to travel with
dogs but dude make him small okay look I
don't even try with my dogs and their
smallest [ __ ] but this person in the
hotel where we were staying at they were
staying at the Hilton or something in
Knoxville dude they brought a [ __ ]
have you ever seen a Great Dane I have
seen Great Danes on the Internet okay I
have not seen great day I've seen Great
Danes from afar in real life hey have
you ever had an elevator have you been
in an elevator had the elevator doors
open up and there was a Great Dane there
first of all I thought I was in Narnia
okay cuz a Great Dane is way too big I
almost [ __ ] my pants I [ __ ] my pants
last night I almost pulled a [ __ ]
George Brett Brett double type of [ __ ]
dude Great Danes are people dressed in
dog costumes they're so big they're not
very big they're so big do you know what
they are too big dude the doors opened
up to the [ __ ] elevator a Great Dane
was there and it looked like it was
gonna say hi I looked at the Great Dane
and the first thought I had was where
are your clothes you're naked that's how
big a Great Dane is a Great Dane is as
big as a big guy bro his balls and dick
were all out it was like what what's
going on put [ __ ] shorts on your
animal you can't have a dog with a
[ __ ] bigger dick than you all right
this thing was so big I mean if it
wanted to end my life it would have done
it in
four seconds a little bit like a horror
movie where I was like clicking the
[ __ ] thing no no here it comes and
then it would have just [ __ ] burst it
dude it so big it was wearing jewelry
this thing was so [ __ ] big it had a
backwards hat on dude it was so big this
Great Dane was so it came up to my
[ __ ] chest on all fours not standing
up if I wanted to ride it I needed a
[ __ ] ladder and the [ __ ] guy was
just walking it into the oh I had to
like scale the wall of the elevator to
get the [ __ ] out it's my heart's [ __ ]
stopped dude and it do and it's
beautiful but it's huge and they only
live to be [ __ ] five or some [ __ ]
because they're so big and [ __ ] up and
they probably shouldn't be that big
health-wise they won't they live to be
like [ __ ] eight and then they just
get their organs or like what's going on
and that it's go Porsche and explode
because we're not supposed to Peter the
pig um anyway it was so [ __ ] big I
couldn't believe it
but yet don't have a dog with a bigger
dick than you don't have a dog with a
bigger [ __ ] than you you know what
I'm talking about the dogs
[ __ ] you ever see that [ __ ]
YouTube video of the elephants sitting
down on a guy and it goes in the
elephant's [ __ ] and the guy ended up
with like living somehow he ended up
winning that exchange but he went in the
elephant's [ __ ] for a little bit
imagine that dude and elephants sat on a
guy and [ __ ] it was probably the guy
had to be a little bit shorter I was
probably my opener cuz he's five only
five nine but he had he sat on the
[ __ ] and the guy goes just goes I met
him being in an elephants [ __ ] the
guy just goes imagine imagine thinking
oh I'm in the elephant's [ __ ]
it's somewhere he sits on a guy it's not
well that wasn't the one I saw but the
elephant sits on a guy and he got the
guy goes in his [ __ ] I saw this on
the Internet it wasn't [ __ ] Photoshop
it was a real thing but that's
unbelievable
they don't have that happen huh don't
have enough how about never be behind a
[ __ ] elephant say this great Dame bro
just and and and and but don't bring but
bring a small dog to a hotel you know
don't bring a [ __ ] horse I mean
imagine checking in that's why I could
never work a lip regular job if I was a
if I was in a hotel and I was just like
oh yeah well Dave great do you know a
half so what's up you need two rooms
right I'm field person be like nine in
one room okay well you need an extra bed
right no oh no but the Great Dane oh no
I could just chill my hotel oh well no I
can't because of how big it is so we're
gonna get you an extra room great day
night [ __ ] mustache mm-hmm